Обережно, бо я зараз...
Я боюся...
Ти йди, Мар'ян,
на середину і ось там ставай.
Отако посунь і там можеш
собі стояти й триматися.
Ні, я просто буду керувати кораблем.
Добре, будеш.
Оствиця — це взагалі назва річки давня.
Ми вирішили її взяти як і назву парку,
і назву проєкту.
І назва нашого клубу
історичної реконструкції теж «Оствиця».
Тут ми створюємо прадавні човни,
робимо реконструкцію Давньої Русі X–XI століття,
створюємо реконструкції прадавніх будинків,
і відтворюємо побут, що був тисячу років тому.
Взагалі я дизайнер, художник.
Займався поліграфією, зовнішньою рекламою.
Це була робота, в принципі було цікаво.
Але потім комп'ютер трішки вже почав втомлювати.
Я відкрив для себе знову велосипед.
У віці, мабуть, після 30-ти
почали мандрувати, досліджувати.
Я почав шукати якісь цікавинки.
У нас зараз проблема культури,
з туризму я маю на увазі,
що не створюють ніяких локацій.
Тобто люди не акцентують увагу
на якості цих локацій.
Тримай, я буду діставати по одному,
бо вони тут просто...
І цю сітку береш?
Все беру, діставай весь рюкзак.
Можна заходити.
♪ Йожин з Бажин ♪
Диви який.
Цей кращий?
Ану на, спробуй, дунь.
♪ Тууууу ♪
Парк розташований поряд
з Басівкутським городищем,
це пам'ятка національного значення.
Тут було тисячу років тому городище в XI–XII столітті.
Ці об'єкти були такими
своєрідними і культурними центрами,
невеликими були і такі точки,
перевалочні місця,
через які проходили торговці.
Це давньоруське городище,
в XII столітті люди з цього городища пішли.
Городище — це така укріплена територія.
Вони є різних типів.
Наприклад, є мисового типу,
це якщо тут подивитися,
ось цей, що великий мис.
Вони шматок відрізали, перекопали,
сюди трохи накинули,
це насправді гора, не рукотворне.
От вони шматок просто відрізали і туди накидали,
щоб вал зробити.
Це городище замкового типу.
Тут був намісник.
Поряд ліворуч і праворуч було по одному поселенню.
І в разі якогось нападу люди ховалися в городищі.
Утеплення, це називається утеплення.
Треба його перероблювати,
воно вже не працює.
Класно виглядає.
Що стосується городища — ми плануємо
зробити тут знову розкопки.
Що стосується парку історичної реконструкції —
насамперед у нас буде такий акцент на човни.
Плюс ми плануємо зараз створити
цілу давньоруську вулицю,
створити будиночок теслі, будиночок гончара,
будиночок коваля тощо.
Майже повний цикл ремесл, які були в давнину.
І спробувати населити персонажами,
які були в ті часи.
Ми робили маршрут «Горинський берег».
Я написав просто в Фейсбуці:
«Приходьте, хто може, хто хоче допомогти».
Прийшов один Олег.
Ми вдвох три дні розчищали 15 км джунглів.
Стараємось використовувати
все-таки автентичні матеріали,
той самий льон і дерев'яні нагелі,
по максимуму так, як це було в ті часи.
Як вони класно тут виглядають.
Дуже класно.
Це просто бомба.
Це довбаночки.
Треба тільки зробити, під що їх швартувати.
Ото там поставити, тут, тут.
Ось це перший об'єкт,
це взагалі, з чого почалася наша вся діяльність.
Це копія ґокстецького дракара.
Зменшена, звісно, копія тому,
що реальний він 25 метровий,
а ми зробили 9 метрову копію його.
Взяли креслення, данський музей «Роскільде»,
і за тими кресленнями зробили вже
ось цей перший наш об'єкт.
Він був досить важливий, іміджевий,
щоб люди побачили, що ми щось можемо зробити.
Човен як об'єкт — це трошки простіше,
ніж взятися одразу за городище.
Майже п'ять місяців вивчали інформацію, теорію,
консультувалися зі спеціалістами,
і за три місяці зробили вже
повністю готовий до спуску на воду.
На носі човна зазвичай були дракони,
тому «дракар» називався.
Там були «снейккари», де змія на носі,
й інші за розмірами човни,
у них так само є різні різновиди тих човнів.
Взагалі, це лодія, тільки варязька.
З певними особливостями.
Якщо хтось не знає, чим відрізняється
наша давньоруська від дракара,
то тяжко досить відрізнити.
Але особливості є.
Туристичний потенціал є в будь-якого місця,
абсолютно будь-якого, хоч яке воно.
В нас легше: в нас гарна природа,
гарна історична є частина, історичне підґрунтя.
Тут узагалі потенціал шалений.
Приклад є: тут просто були чагарі, бур'яни,
борщовик і шалений огірок,
а зараз це локація,
на яку щодня приїжджає купа рівнян,
і ми вже відомі по всій Україні.
Це цікаво насамперед, це наповнює життя сенсом.
Тобто, якось просто ходити на роботу
з 9 до 6 це тяжко, неможливо.
Тут ми працюємо в будь-яких умовах,
в морози такі шалені,
але це має сенс.
Ти бачиш, чим воно наповнює місто,
як воно змінює місто.
Ти бачиш, як ти змінюєш простір.
Бачиш, як ти змінюєш історію свого міста,
своєї держави.
Ти відчуваєш, що реально на щось впливаєш.
Тому що це місце змінює простір навколо себе.
Ми маємо цей проміжок історії,
той, що був за часи Давньої Русі,
ми маємо його зберегти й акцентувати, що він наш.
Тому що зараз йде перетягування ковдри Росією,
вони позиціонують, що це їхня історія, їхня країна,
що Русь — це там десь, не тут, а там.
І ми намагаємося цю ковдру повернути.
Подивися!
Ану давай.
О, диви, молодець!
Треба ще, я покажу, як треба.
Я ж попадав.
Молодець, ти ж попадаєш.
Треба ще раз.